ich habe am ersten advent dieses bild
von einer freundin zugesandt bekommen
über mottet aber es dann auf meiner
facebook seite weitergeleitet und habe
meinen freunden und fans einen schönen
ersten advent gewünscht seit einem monat
bekomme ich eine e mail von einem
fotografen aus wien er versucht jetzt
daraus geld zu schlagen und behauptet
das wäre sein bild und erhält darauf
urheberrechte ich habe nichts im
internet gefunden wo eine verlinkung
seines namens ist bitter können sie mir
helfen was für einen aufreger also an
kempkens wie sehen sie dass das so ein
harmloses internet bild mit frohe
weihnachten
und jetzt hat der arme mann so ein ärger
also ist das wirklich totale abzocke
oder ist das wirklich eine verletzung
des urheberrechts wie sehen sie das
also im moment hört sich das auf den
ersten blick so ein bisschen nach
abzocke an was hier passiert allerdings
dürfen wir das auch nicht so ganz auf
die leichte schulter nehmen also wenn
man urheberrechtlich geschützte fotos
oder inhalte selbst nutzt vor allem den
kommerziellen nutzt in irgendeinem
bereich dann kann das schon so weit
gehen dass man eine abmahnung bekommt
dass man unterlassungsansprüchen sich
begegnen zieht und das passiert relativ
schnell denn man muss sich schon sicher
sein welches foto man im internet nutzt
es ist also nicht so dass man sagt ich
konnte ja nicht sehen dass das geschützt
ist erstmal müssen wir quasi von hause
aus davon ausgehen dass ein foto auch
geschützt ist davon müssen wir
eigentlich ausgehen
nur wenn wir uns sicher sind das heißt
nicht geschützt ist dann können wir es
vorhatten dh die beweislast ist also
umgekehrt nicht der inhaber dieser
rechte muss nachweisen dass das
irgendwie veröffentlicht wurde oder
dergleichen sondern man muss sich schon
sicher sein wenn man das verwertet wenn
das aber hier so eine rein private
nutzung ist also wenn man das sozusagen
anlässlich eines weines freundschafts
grußes weiter benutzt dann würde ich das
eigentlich für unproblematisch halten
da müsste man vielleicht noch mal
genauer sehen in welchem zusammenhang er
das foto genutzt wurde und inwieweit das
geschützt ist also tatsächlich glaube er
per watts etwas zu verbreiten ist nicht
so schlimm weil deshalb bleibt wirklich
im privaten bereich
hier wurde es auf facebook
postet gut ist die frage ist es halt
eine gruppe oder tatsächlich öffentlich
aber wie geht es dann weiter soll ich da
einfach bezahlen um das thema aus der
welt zu schaffen soll ich da
widersprechen oder wie gehe ich davor im
grunde genommen immer so ein bisschen so
eine einzelfall frage man bekommt ja so
unterlassungsansprüche und meistens auch
sind die strafbewehrt das heißt da steht
also drin für den fall der wiederholung
muss der betroffene 5000 euro zahlen
da würde ich immer sehr zurückhaltend
mit umgehen so etwas zu unterschreiben
denn wenn man das tut ist man sozusagen
mit einem bein schon so halb drin
deshalb sollte man sich das wirklich
genau anschauen ob dann verstoß gegeben
ist und das ist tatsächlich etwas schwer
so pauschal zu beantworten
aber bitte immer ganz nett sein und wenn
man tatsächlich die fotos genutzt hat
öffentlich dann kann durchaus eine
haftung gegeben sein also ganz so leicht
ist nicht dann muss man jeden fall wird
mich genau betrachten ja sollte es
tatsächlich internetabzocke sein wer ist
wirklich eine ganz fiese sache aber klar
werden natürlich seine rechte da
beschädigt sieht sollte natürlich auf
der anderen seite auch dagegen vorgehen
wir wollen mal schauen wie sich dieser
fall weiterentwickelt